I was sent an email with an amazing
question how can one have a minimal
slower approach to life when working in
such a fast-paced industry as social
media maybe you work in social media or
maybe you just want to keep in touch
with your friends and family or you
maybe just want to sell on Facebook
Marketplace whatever the case may be if
you're asking yourself this question how
can I do both how can I use social media
to my advantage or to serve others while
also adopting a more minimal slower
approach to life if you're asking
yourself this question I first want to
challenge you with the idea that you
already had such an approach to life to
begin with it was no accident that I
used the word regain a slow approach to
life in the title of this video I was
recently listening to an incredible
audiobook Simplicity parenting and it's
basically a book on minimalism but for
parents rather than it be focused on
material items it's all about having a
reverence for childhood
and as I listened intently I came to the
realization that my kids my
four-year-old and two-year-old are
Masters at slow living
when I tell Anna that we have to hurry
up and get into the car because we have
to go somewhere she'll stop on the way
because she saw a cool stick and since
she saw this cool stick now she has to
pretend it's a tree and plant it on the
way after I tell her to quit that
because we gotta go she'll see a cool
feather or rock and you gotta look at
that
if you carefully watch a kid playing in
nature you might see that they submerge
themselves in the present
they're not worrying about what's next
I realize that many of you may not be
parents but you are all children at one
point
and somewhere along your life
someone like me rushed you along
stop getting messy quit playing around
hurry up we've gotta go and you began to
live your life more focused on doing
rather than being up next I'm going to
share with you some tips that I've found
helpful for me to help me live life more
slowly in a world that constantly
bombards us with screens and devices
but I first want to remind you that slow
living and savoring simple moments in
life is not a new skill that you have to
learn it's embedded within you and by
removing excess from your life in this
case technological distractions and
devices you can get back to that state
of creativity and awe that you had as a
child
when it comes to having balance with
technology it's definitely an ongoing
process especially if you work in social
media so hopefully you'll find the tips
that I share with you to be helpful and
please share your own tips as well
because what works for me may not work
for everybody else in relationship to
your technology use that is not an
absolute necessity I would first urge
you to consider which activities you
find to be energizing and which you find
to be training for example I enjoy
editing I'm still learning but it's such
fun for me I find Value in it I also
find listening to my favorite slow
living and compassionate productivity
YouTubers to be really helpful I learned
a lot from them by contrast if I give in
to the temptation to watch YouTube
shorts nine times out of ten it was a
complete waste of my time and I gained
nothing from it so maybe consider what
specific activities you can cut back on
ideally it's the things that are not
serving you any good purpose or that are
actually causing harm for you I would
also consider unfollowing or unfriending
any individual that is not necessary for
your work purposes so maybe having a
client-only policy see you may not
necessarily want to unfriend or unfollow
everybody and that's totally okay if you
don't want to do that but for some
people they have great balance if they
keep work separate from personal life
and that can be a great way to have the
balance but maybe you do want to keep
some friends or some individuals that
are not necessarily business related
what I would definitely urge you to do
is to consider which of these
individuals are causing you to compare
yourself constantly or to feel like you
have to purchase new things maybe it's
that individual that seems to have an
extravagant lifestyle or maybe they just
have awesome style of clothing and you
want to have the things that they have
if you have friends or people that
you're following or subscribed to that
are constantly making you compare your
life or to feel less than I would urge
you to consider that maybe you're better
off without those so take a short moment
or maybe a long moment if you have
hundreds of people that you're
subscribed to or thousands of friends on
social media and really ask yourself
what effect do these individuals or
these accounts have on my life is this
somebody that is constantly making me
compare myself well for making me feel
less than or is this person teaching me
things that are guiding my life in a
positive direction once you've taken the
time to do this you'll find that
mindfulness is truly at the heart of
this issue when you take a moment to
step back and analyze how you're
spending your time on social media
you'll begin to see areas where you can
then improve and after you've done this
set rules for yourself and be specific
for example a rule can be as simple as
no watching YouTube shorts unless it's
from people that you're subscribed to no
using social media for entertainment or
no using your phone for the first two
hours of your day I remember hearing Jay
Shetty say something along the lines of
you wouldn't invite hundreds of people
into your bedroom the first thing after
you wake up in the morning but that's
exactly what we do when we pop open our
phones the first thing after we wake up
we're inviting hundreds of people into
the bedroom of our mind another tip that
I find helpful especially having a
full-time job while having this YouTube
channel is that I schedule specific
tasks so for example I respond to emails
and comments at round six in the morning
because I usually wake up at 5am by then
I'm a little bit more clear-minded and
it's also before my kids usually wake up
around seven this not only makes it so
that I'm not distracted throughout the
day but also it means that I don't
accidentally miss something because I'm
sporadically answering and that I'm
guilty of forgetting about it and
leaving them behind I'm sorry you guys
I've gotten better at it but scheduling
has definitely made it helpful also
whenever possible turn off your
notifications it's very difficult to
keep focused when you're constantly
having distractions but if you're
worried that you might miss something
that you need to respond to quickly then
maybe consider adding another time
throughout your day that you've
scheduled to check on emails or messages
another personal rule that I really love
for myself is that I do not allow myself
to use a phone during meal times so if
it rings then I just let it ring and
then I call back after I'm done
one because I want to show my friends
and my family that I value my time with
them but two I also realized that I need
to slow down meal times can be a great
time to take a break and be fully
present in what you're doing
whether you're by yourself or not
it's also an act of self-care and
mindfulness we need breaks
so give yourself some Grace and allow
yourself to actually enjoy your meals
there's a lot more that I could say on
this topic but I'll leave you with
another rule that helps me tremendously
this one I don't even have to think
about because it's just set and done no
social media TV scrolling Etc at least
two hours before bed to be able to feel
and be our best we have to prioritize
rest I've talked about it in my video
how to wake up at 5am feeling glorious
if you want to learn more about how to
prioritize sleep and really improve your
sleep habits but this is something that
has helped me just tremendously in
general so that I can slow down and
allow myself the time to really just
wind down and relax before bed setting
the example for my children as well so
what I have done is that at seven
o'clock every night any unnecessary apps
are automatically disabled so things
like checking the weather or any social
media applications automatically gray
and this serves as a reminder that it's
time to slow down I also have a do not
disturb that's automatically set every
night because usually my husband and I
are in bed by 8 30 and it never fails we
would have a phone call at 9 10
sometimes 11 o'clock at night when we
get up early in the morning he wakes up
around 4 or 4 30. so having a phone call
come through at 11 o'clock at night was
not exactly ideal if you work on a
desktop it may be easier to just step
back turn it off and walk away but our
phones tend to just follow us throughout
the day so having these limits that are
automatically programmed that you don't
have to think about can serve as a
reminder to yourself it is time to slow
down so really the underlying message
here is to be mindful of having
boundaries for when and where it is okay
to use it for work or entertainment by
setting rules and schedules this way you
can ensure that you're taking the breaks
that you need while also getting things
done and if you're really feeling
overwhelmed check out my playlist on
digital minimalism for more
encouragement on this topic I hope that
what I've shared with you today has been
helpful I know that some people want to
quit social media but they can't because
that's what they do for work and some
individuals don't even want to quit they
just want to have better balance with it
and I think it's totally doable if you
have any tips of your own please share
in the comments below so that we can all
learn from each other I thank you guys
so much for your support especially for
my subscribers thank you so much I hope
that my videos will improve and get
better and there will be more to come if
there's anything particular that you
would like to see please don't hesitate
to email or just leave it down in the
comments below again thank you so much
and I will see you in the next one bye
for now
so much noise
eventually
for a better rest for a better morning
the next day
oh my goodness
so many distractions
see I tell you this wasn't even my phone
it was my husband's phone
there